the crypto markets are collapsing
bitcoin has lost more than half its
value and tons of smaller projects are
imploding left and right lots of pundits
have tried to offer explanations for
what's going on but none of them really
capture the full picture by now we've
all heard the basic high-level story a
global pandemic unprecedented levels of
stimulus manufacturing slowdowns record
inflation rising interest rates while
it's generally true that higher interest
rates have triggered market sell-offs
and a big move away from high-risk
assets like crypto
recent fed actions don't tell the whole
story fundamentally crypto is undergoing
an identity crisis is it a store of
value or a way to make payments should
we call it web3 or is that just
confusing and is any of this stuff
actually fully decentralized all of
these points are actively being debated
right now but the biggest question of
all is what year is it this question
isn't a joke in crypto circles though
this is a new technology and we don't
quite know where it'll go so what should
we compare it to is crypto just like the
internet in 1995 poised to explode and
change everything about the way we
interact or should we look to a
different time in history to understand
what's going on well if you ask a crypto
critic they'll tell you that we should
be comparing crypto to a much earlier
period in history 1637 to be specific
that's because 1637 was the year that
tulip mania collapsed during the dutch
golden age and it's useful to study
previous speculative bubbles to
understand current market conditions see
tulips were not indigenous to holland in
the 16th century but once they started
getting imported through dutch trade
routes they became a luxury item anyone
who owned a mansion with a large garden
had to have tulips to impress their
neighbors not all tulips were created
equal though and those with interesting
multicolored patterns or stripes could
sell for much more than plain tulips
sound familiar well demand for the most
exquisite tulips led to rising prices as
wealthy collectors began paying higher
and higher prices eventually that led to
speculation with a long chain of traders
buying expensive tulips in the hopes of
selling them down the line at the peak
of the mania a single bulb could be
worth as much as a mansion in amsterdam
this also sounds a bit familiar
eventually people started using credit
to purchase bulbs which further fueled
price spikes it was unsustainable though
ultimately tulips were just flowers nice
decorations but essentially useless
beyond their visual aesthetic so the
bubble burst the market rationalized
over-leveraged tulip buyers went
bankrupt and prices collapsed the entire
saga was documented in a book called
memoirs of extraordinary popular
delusions and the madness of crowds and
lives on as a warning about the dangers
of speculative frenzies to this day so
you can see why critics of crypto point
to the tulip mania of 1637 so frequently
we've seen crypto prices soar we've seen
individual nfts that sell for as much as
a mansion and we've seen people use
credit to leverage their bets there's
one problem with this analogy though the
entire tulip bubble really only lasted
from november to may just seven months
from the beginning to the end crypto on
the other hand has been going on
multi-year bull runs now regularly for
the past decade and perhaps most
interestingly historians are now
debating whether or not dutch tulip
mania actually existed at all while
there are few verifiable accounts of
tulips selling for more than six figures
in today's dollars there isn't
substantial evidence that the mania was
anywhere near as widespread as had been
reported so while there are clearly
parts of the crypto world where
comparisons to the seven month tulip
mania make perfect sense it doesn't
quite fit the overall story here there's
a lot more going on so let's dig into
what the major proponents of crypto have
to say about it after all we're talking
about a new technology here not some
random flower so it makes sense to look
at how other technologies developed
right well that's what the pro crypto
crowd argues and they've anchored
comparisons to the internet in 1995. the
impact of the internet is undeniable now
but back in 1995 it wasn't so clear only
15 million people had internet access at
the time and the technology was widely
mocked as a joke there's a great david
letterman clip where he makes fun of
bill gates for suggesting that the
internet could be a better way to stream
content compared to the radio on the
internet or on some computer deal they
were going to broadcast a baseball game
you could listen to a baseball game on
your computer and i just thought to
myself
does radio ring a bell
clip looks hilarious in hindsight since
internet streaming is now completely
dominant but perhaps most importantly
very few people predicted exactly what
the internet would unlock a lot of the
first generation internet businesses
were simple ports of existing services
like listening to a baseball game on
your computer but all that changed as
the internet became ubiquitous and
entirely new services developed on top
of it it's easy to compare youtube to
traditional television but it's clearly
very different now when you look at the
recommendation algorithm comments
section and ability to subscribe which
you should do by the way only 15 million
people use the internet in 1995 and it
went on to change everything so that's
why the crypto community loves drawing
comparisons to this time period the
total number of ethereum users is right
around 15 million so it's easy to say
crypto usage is right where the internet
was in 1995 this is about to explode and
the internet also had a very slow
initial phase it all started with
arpanet in 1969 then the first email
client launched in 1975. in the 80s we
got the domain name service and the
launch of america online and it wasn't
until 1993 that html was introduced
allowing for the easy creation of new
websites it took the internet 25 years
to get to the point where 15 million
people could use it and it was still a
joke looking back at the history of
crypto tells a similar story 25 years
ago the first cryptocurrency project
digicash launched and didn't get very
far and it's been a full 13 years since
bitcoin launched so if we compare
ethereum usage data in 2022 to internet
usage data in 1995 we get a very rosy
picture after all in 1998 google was
founded and by 2005 more than one
billion people had internet access if
the comparison holds we would expect a
billion people to be using crypto
regularly by 2032. there's a problem
with this comparison though see picking
ethereum users as a benchmark is a bit
arbitrary you could just as easily
broaden the scope to include all
cryptocurrency users and when you do the
numbers don't track quite as well
although it's hard to measure most
estimates peg 2015 as the year when 15
million people were using crypto and if
we benchmark against that we should see
nearly a billion crypto users today and
we're pretty far away from that and then
there's the question of user value it's
one thing to say that crypto will
continue to grow and eventually
transform the internet it's an entirely
different thing to price that future
transformation in today it's useful here
to look at the value created by your
average modern internet user there are
around 5 billion people using the
internet and the total value of all
internet companies is around 10 trillion
dollars that implies a value of 2 000
per user it's a rough number but it's a
reasonable benchmark now let's look at
crypto at the peak crypto was worth
around 3 trillion dollars if we divided
that by the 15 million users you get a
value per user of 200 000
a full hundred times more per user so
you can see why critics of crypto think
that the sector is so overvalued even if
you accept the idea that it's early and
usage will continue to grow over time
that growth is basically priced in and
most critics argue that the vast
majority of the 15 million active users
are just speculators not people who get
real value from web3 services back in
1995 people went to the internet to find
niche information connect with other
people on messaging boards or send
messages faster than mailing letters
they didn't have a financial incentive
to use the internet they chose to log on
because it delivered real value over
newspapers radio and the postal service
but this comparison isn't completely
fair after all a big chunk of that three
trillion dollars in crypto was tied up
in bitcoin it's a completely separate
use case from web3 bitcoin isn't about
transforming the internet it's about
storing value and here's where we get
back to timelines bitcoin believers
don't want to anchor it in 1995 because
this isn't about the internet it's about
money they say that we should instead be
looking at the year 1920 specifically in
germany this is because germany went
through a period of staggering
hyperinflation and bitcoin famously has
a fixed supply world war one was
incredibly expensive for germany and in
order to cover the costs they suspended
the gold standard instead of using an
income tax to fund the war effort german
emperor wilhelm ii decided to use debt
the idea was simple take out a big loan
to fight the war and after they won they
would be able to impose war reparations
on the defeated allies to pay back the
debts the strategy failed though germany
lost the war and the country was saddled
with massive war debts that it couldn't
afford to pay back instead of getting
reparations paid to them the treaty of
versailles mandated that germany would
have to pay there was still hope that
germany would be able to pay these debts
the western front of the war had been
fought mostly in france and belgium so
the majority of german factories were
left untouched but once the first
payment came due in june of 1921
inflation started spiraling every time
the government printed more money the
value of the currency would collapse
further leading to a single us dollar
being worth over 4 trillion german marks
it was an economic disaster and any
german citizen who held wealth in cash
got absolutely wiped out and so you can
see why proponents of bitcoin like to
compare the united states today to
germany in the early 1920s we're already
seeing increases in the money supply and
now inflation is starting to spike if
this gets out of control holding a fixed
supply currency like bitcoin could be
incredibly valuable there are a few
problems with this though first
proponents of crypto have been saying
that hyperinflation is right around the
corner for over a decade now after all
bitcoin was created shortly after the
2008 financial crisis as a direct
response to government bailouts and
money printing but inflation has finally
arrived so it should be bitcoin's time
to shine right well we certainly haven't
seen that in the market even though
inflation has been higher than
expectations for months now bitcoin is
in free fall gold which has historically
been seen as the ultimate inflation
hedge has held up pretty well but
bitcoin hasn't so what's going on well
it likely comes back to speculation even
though there are a lot of bitcoin
holders who believe in the inflation
hedge story that's not what's been
driving the price for the last few years
instead cheap money from low interest
rates and fiscal stimulus have led
people to hunt for higher returns high
growth tech stocks spiked a ton and so
did cryptocurrencies as interest rates
rise and people begin pulling back on
riskier investments prices fall and
that's what we're seeing today in a
previous video i said that bitcoin had
proven itself as a sort of digital gold
someone recently called me out in my
discord for this which you should
totally join by the way and they were
100 right bitcoin isn't functioning as a
digital gold at all in fact it's
inversely correlated with gold but the
real question is will bitcoin ever
function as an inflation hedge even if
it doesn't today gold is worth around 10
trillion dollars so if bitcoin could
replace gold as the go-to inflation
hedge it would certainly be a good
investment right well that's a
complicated question because again it
all depends on the timeline sure if
bitcoin suddenly becomes as stable as
gold next year you could see the price
10x but that seems unlikely if on the
other hand it takes 30 years to
stabilize the price could still 10x but
that doesn't make it a good investment
making 10x in 30 years is roughly an 8
percent gain annually which is less than
the average stock market return gold has
been used for thousands of years bitcoin
has only been around for 15 so it's
worthwhile to think about where you want
to benchmark these assets the time it
takes to realize a big return is
incredibly important it underpins the
entire technology investment process
it's not enough to make 10x if it takes
30 years most technology investors have
a 10-year time horizon this idea of
annual return rate drives so many
decisions in our economy and
misalignment here can really shift the
deployment rate of a new technology it's
possible for a new technology to be
transformative but still not make for a
great investment perhaps instead of 1637
or 1921 or 1995 we should instead look
at something more recent 2006. see in
2006 venture capitalists were extremely
excited about a new type of technology
that could potentially reshape the world
the market was absolutely massive and
consumers wanted the products i'm
talking about cleantech and it wound up
being one of the biggest investment
disasters in history in 2006 al gore
released an inconvenient truth
popularizing the idea that climate
change was real and needed to be stopped
the public quickly got behind the idea
and began envisioning a future powered
by clean energy solar wind nuclear and
even tidal energy began gaining traction
investors poured more than 25 billion
dollars into clean tech companies from
2006 to 2011 but it didn't work they
lost over half their money and it led to
a decade-long stagnation in the sector
it was an unexpected outcome because the
value seemed so obvious clean and
abundant energy is always in demand but
a variety of factors dragged the
industry down and led to subpar
investment returns today the clean
energy umbrella still contains some
incredibly promising technologies but
the investment returns during the 2006
funding boom just didn't live up to
expectations so what's the relationship
to crypto here well i think it shows
that it's important to separate
technological considerations from
investment considerations whenever
people start arguing about crypto they
tend to fall in one of two categories
either they love the technology and
think the price will only go up or they
think the technology is useless and the
value will ultimately be zero there is
an alternative path though the hype
could be real the technology could be
impactful but it could still make for a
bad investment the best investment you
could make in cleantech back in 2006 was
probably just buying solar panels and
putting them on your house even though
clean tech companies underperformed the
technology itself really was valuable
now regardless of your view of crypto or
any other financial market you need an
investing app to express that view and
that brings us to today's sponsor
public.com public is an app where you
can invest in stocks etfs and crypto
with any amount of money public is great
because they put a big focus on investor
education if you search for john coogan
in the app you can see what trends i
follow and scroll a feed of updates
about whatever you're interested in it's
really cool to see what investors on the
app are saying about specific trends
especially right now there are a bunch
of youtubers on there like phil defranco
graham stefan cody ko and thousands more
on public you can trade thousands of
stocks etfs and crypto and there's no
commissions on standard stock trades
plus public doesn't sell your trades to
market makers like other investment apps
they route the trades directly to the
exchanges you'll get a free stock worth
between three dollars and a thousand
dollars when you go to public.com john
coogan and create an account so get
started today maybe you think a certain
part of the market is overvalued maybe
you think another area is undervalued
whatever you decide make sure you go to
public.com john coogan to get a free
stock from three dollars to a thousand
dollars i'll leave the link below
financial markets are extremely
difficult to understand but if you watch
this video on why tech stocks crash
you'll definitely have a better idea of
what's going on thanks for watching